guten morgen im neuen jahr und herzlich
willkommen in der sternstunde religion
sie lebt bescheiden in basel und ist
eine der bedeutenden schweizer
theologinnen sie hat in ihrem leben eine
wende vom streng katholisch erzogenen
mädchen zur kritischen theologin
vollzogen
helen schimmel straumann sie gehört zu
den begründern innen der feministischen
theologie
ihr spezialgebiet ist die bibel
insbesondere das alte testament
wie kommt es eigentlich zu dieser
liebesgeschichte mit der bibel ja das
kann ich vielleicht gar nicht so ganz
erklären ich habe die bibel schon sehr
früh angefangen zu lesen dann habe ich
herbert tag kennengelernt in luzern
großer theologe der teufel ausgetrieben
ja und er hat mir die bibel sehr
schmackhaft bei verkauft und er hat auch
mir privat damals schon hebräisch
stunden gegeben ich durfte also schon
hebräisch lernen die sprache in dem ich
sprach richter liebe sollte das als
geschrieben ist ja und das hat mir ich
habe sowieso gerne sprachen gehabt
deshalb mir sehr imponiert und man kann
dann auch vieles besser verstehen wenn
man das richtige besetzt und das alte
testament ist für mich deswegen einfach
später wichtiger geworden als das neue
weil das so konkret ist zu erdverbunden
und das ist einfach er nicht so
abgehoben wie das neue testament dass es
viele spielt immer in den oberen
regionen während das alte testament das
ist ja auch eine volks geschichte also
es ist auch eine ein geschichtsbuch und
ein geschichtenbuch und das läuft über
1000 jahre und das neue testament ist
halt in sehr kurzer zeit entstanden
also sie haben ja der tag erwähnt ein
großer luzerner theologe eben sich mit
der sexualität im alten und im neuen
testament auseinandergesetzt hat er hat
sozusagen die sexualität in der bibel
rehabilitiert hat gezeigt es ist nicht
so verkorkst
dass sich ein thema das sie auch
interessiert hat wann haben sie denn als
frau gemerkt dass da etwas nicht stimmt
in dieser christlichen tradition also
dass etwas ich habe ich erinnere mich
dass ich in meinem ersten oder in meinem
zweiten semester in tübingen der rp
tages ja dann nach tübingen gegangen und
ich habe in tübingen angefangen mit dem
theologiestudium und dass ich immer ganz
entsetzt gefragt habe ist es eigentlich
war dass die frau an allem schuld ist
und dass sie die ursache ist vom bösen
und eine verführung das habe ich ihn so
gefragt und hat er gesagt das ist
quatsch das stimmt so nicht
aber ich bin an dieser frage nicht
weiter nachgegangen
das kam erst 20 jahre später wieder ich
hab dann also die ganz normale theorie
den ganzen gang gemacht und auch
promotion und so und hatte sehr viel
sehr viel arbeit und sehr viel
widerstand auch auf diesem weg aber erst
als ich so knapp 40 war
da ist es mir dann aufgegangen dass da
einfach grundsätzlich was nicht stimmt
wie kam es denn jetzt zu dieser wende
von eben dem streng katholisch erzogenen
mädchen erzogen das ist ein derzeit auch
normal hinzu in der kritischen
feministischen theologie also kritisch
waren schon immer und etwas frech auch
das hat mir nicht gefallen diese streng
katholisch das war zum teil sehr bigott
also zwar nicht nur streng katholisch
sondern ich hab sehr eben gerade durch
die bibel was ich da gelesen habe habe
ich gedacht das kann so nicht sein dass
man so nebensächlichkeiten so ernst
nimmt und die wichtigen sachen dann
einfach ad acta legen zum beispiel dass
das war damals dass das freitagsgebet
dass man freitag kein fleisch essen
durfte das wurde sowie ein wie ein
unglaublich wichtiger wichtige sache
oder das nüchternheit gebot dass man
nichts der essen trinken da vor der
kommunion das wurde so unglaublich
wichtig genommen und danach ging man vor
die kirche und tratschen über die
anderen und machte die schlecht und so
das passte irgendwie für mich nicht
zusammen
haben sicher viele ältere menschen so in
erinnerung oder diese boote diese über
gebote die das noch so erlebt haben nach
dem krieg in der zeit nach dem krieg ja
das war das war ein es war einfach die
die proportionen stimmte nicht und ich
hab dann eben in der bibel sehr viel
gelesen ich habe ein neues testament
da habe ich alle sätze rot unterstrichen
die mir gefehlt also habe ich heute noch
das habe ich mit 14 15 gelesen und ich
habe einfach gemerkt das stimmt vieles
nicht was ist denn das wesentliche wenn
es nicht die gebote sind das wesentliche
im ganzen in der ganzen bibel ich die
gottesfrage das ist ganz klar also die
der glaube an gott das vertrauen auf
gott das ist das wesentliche und der
biblische gott das wurde ja immer dann
gesagt der alttestamentliche gott ist
ein gott des zornes ein böser gott ein
gewalttätiger gott und der neue
testament licher gott ist ein lieber
gott und so weiter man hat ja ganz
auseinander genommen und ich denke da
hat der antisemitismus auch noch eine
rolle gespielt dass man das alte
testament so ein bisschen links hat
liegen lassen weil das ja die jüdische
bibel war
und das stimmt einfach so gar nicht der
alttestamentliche gott ist warmherzig
und ein liebender gott und ein treuer
gott uns weiter und dann ist es so dass
sich gottesbilder ja im lauf einer
biografie auch wieder verändern können
ja und die habe neue entdeckungen macht
und sie haben sich ja auch im lauf der
bibel verändert also das gottesbild der
bibel ist ja gewachsen
das ist ja im laufe von 1000 jahren das
war ja zuerst noch mal noch nicht mal
monotheistische so das ist ja nicht so
dass in der bibel gott von anfang an der
einzige gewesen ist er war ja damals
noch mit vielen anderen göttern dass
dieser ein gott glaube der monotheismus
ich ja auch erst langsam gewachsen das
gottesbild hat sich entwickelt und so
ist das auch bei jedem menschen denen
welche anderen götter denken sie da sind
die altorientalischen götter also der
java ist er gott israels aber die
anderen völker haben andere götter und
das ist dann erst nach ungefähr 500
jahren
dass man gesagt hat nein es gibt
eigentlich nur einen und der ist für
alle die spuren finden sich da noch
zurück zu ihrer biografie sie haben dann
als erste frau in promoviert eine
doktorarbeit abgegeben da muss dann die
regeln geändert werden dass also auch
laien organisieren dürfen hat ihnen das
geschmeichelt geschmeichelt nicht das
war so ein kampf dass mir da nichts mehr
gespeichert hat das war so kampf es war
soviel kampfes war so viel streit bis
das so weit war die älteren professoren
haben sich alle dagegen gewehrt dass
diese klausel abgeschafft wurde
also dass die wollten dem fürst leuten
an der klausel festhalten
für einen doktortitel ist eine höhere
weihe erforderlich und erst dann mit
viel mit viel knatsch hinter den
kulissen ist das dann abgeschafft worden
und dann war es dann die erste frau die
da promoviert hat das war 1967 68 sie
haben das beschrieben in ihrem buch
meine wege und umwege und da bin ich auf
ein bild gestoßen dass jetzt noch zeigen
will nicht bibel und windeln hat dann
eine zeitung eben aufgrund ihrer
promotion getitelt aber ich mein leben
sie schildern sehr so harmonisch mit
bibel und windeln browser nicht das ist
der titel von von dem stadtanzeiger von
dem kölner stadt anzeiger die haben ja
da die aufnahme gemacht dass das sich da
eben mit meinem älteren sohn sitze und
eine bibel aufgeschlagen habe das haben
wir damals weil das ja eben ein ereignis
war dass zum ersten mal eine frau
promoviert hat aber auch damals war ich
noch nicht
auf dieses feministische thema gestoßen
da habe ich noch ganze sage ich jetzt
mal die die überkommene theologie
weitergemacht aber so ein unbehagen
wurde immer stärker ich kann das nicht
genau beschreiben
nachher mit der zeit lernt man andere
frauen kennen und dann merkte man die
haben das auch die die finden
stimmt etwas in der theologie nicht weil
die männliche theologie hat immer
behauptet wir sprechen für alle
wir sind sozusagen neutral aber das
stimmt nicht sie haben einen männlichen
blickwinkel mit allem was sie behandeln
aber sie von gott reden oder vom himmel
oder von der sünde und diese dieser
weibliche blick also das kam dann immer
intensiver ins gespräch und irgendwann
kam dann das wort feministisch auf das
kam glaube ich aus amerika also das ist
dort schon etwas früher angefangen und
dann haben wir also mit einer gruppe von
frauen angefangen eben anders zu
arbeiten und da ging es eben auch vor
allem das gottesbild das haben wir zu
beginn unseres gesprächs interessiert
und da haben sie dann gesagt eben
herbert haag hat ihnen gesagt das ist
quatsch mit ihrem ford die soll an allem
schuld sein sie haben auch dazu ein buch
geschrieben eva die erste frau der bibel
das haben sie gründlich widerlegt aber
adam da fängt das missverständnis an ist
eben der mensch wird aber doch immer aus
der man genießt das hat man immer das
haben man muss ja wissen dass immer nur
die männer bibel interpretiert haben und
auch bibeln addiert haben oder bibeln
abgeschrieben oder übersetzt haben das
waren immer ausschließlich männer und
adam heißt mensch da ist eigentlich mann
und frau drin
und immer wenn es adam heißt in diesen
biblischen ursprungs geschichten sind
beide gemeint sind immer mein mann und
frau gemeint und aus diesen aus dieser
einheit werden dann 2 und dann kommt
erst die ausdrücke auf ich und ich ja
also mann und frau
das ist in diesem paradies bericht und
das wird sehr drastisch also es wird
bildlich dargestellt durch diese
erschaffung aus der rippe wobei das auch
keine rippe ist das ist ein anderes wort
das hat man später als rippe gelesen und
dass der ganze sinn dieser erzählung es
zu erklären warum aus einer einheit
wieder eine einheit wird wieso mann und
frau immer zusammen
warum sie sich nacheinander sehnen und
dann am schluss wieder ein fleisch
werden das ist eigentlich die ganze
geschichte aber nur das ist richtig
verstehe es gibt ja zwei
schöpfungsbericht im ersten ist es mir
klar da wird
gott erschafft den menschen als mann und
frau im zweiten ist es erschafft den
menschen und dann ist irgendwann die
rede von ordnern die aber eben doch
irgendwie auch eva aus adam und so also
es ist etwas verbindlicher der
reihenfolge her ist es dann doch
schlussendlich auch hier ging es 22 frau
soll sie heißen denn vom mann ist sie
genommen
ja das stimmt ja nicht sie ist nicht vom
band genommen ist von adam genommen
sie untersteht denn vom ich form einer
superrunde einer zersetzung eine fehl-
übersetzt nein es ist keine viel
übersetzt man sieht ja klar dass da
schon bestimmte bestimmte leute am werk
waren die halt gerne gehabt hätten dass
das erste wesen ein mann ist also koran
ist böse mensch heißen ausgenommen nicht
sind sind eigentlich beide aus dem
eingenommen mich und das ist natürlich
als im bild sehr schwer festzustellen
die wollten das in einer geschichte
darstellen und die im griechischen hat
man das hier anders gemacht da hat man
ein einen afro also einen 2
geschlechtlichen menschen am anfang
gehabt das ist ein ähnliches bild
aber muss das ebenfalls bild sehen und
nicht als eine ein faktor man hat das ja
früher so als fakt genommen die ganze
schöpfungsgeschichte ist so passiert wie
sie da steht das ist ja das ist ja
wirklich überholt das behauptet heute
keiner mehr außer fundamentalisten
das sind ja einfach bildhafte
vorstellung wie es am anfang gewesen ist
sagen sie schon angedeutet mit dem
verhältnis zwischen mann und frau
zwischen mensch und gott sie haben ja
sehr schöne bilder herausgesucht wir
haben hier die darstellung etwas älter
aus dem zwölften jahrhundert monreale
sizilien
ist eine sehr schöne darstellung die
eigentlich den sündenfall eine große
wertung wir haben dieses paar von dem
wir sprechen
wir haben den baum der erkenntnis wir
haben eine andeutung der schlange ja wir
haben im ersten jahr also bis zum
ungefähr elf 1200 haben wir keinerlei
bilder wo man sehen kann dass die frau
stärker beschuldigt wird oder dass die
frau näher an die sünde herangerückt ist
als der mann in der bibel heißt bisher
korrekter weise die schlange
ja die schlange wird aber nicht die
schlange vor euch wirklich lange gehofft
das heißt täuscht nicht verführt sondern
sie täuscht die eva sie macht er ja was
vor
sie führt sie ja sozusagen aufs glatteis
aber die e von von der frau heißt es
nicht dass sie verführt dass es auch nie
so und weil sie eben das wort sündenfall
gebraucht haben das kommt auch in dem
text nicht vor
die in dem ganzen text kommt auch das
hunde nicht vor
das ist alles erst von augustinus
reingekommen incorrect möchte man vom
garten eden springer hat den läden um
sünden und in dieser ganzen zeit gibt es
also nur bilder die sehr paritätisch
mann und frau darstellen unter einem
baum mit der schlange und nach 1200
fängt es an immer frauenfeindlicher zu
werden
da gibt es die darstellung eben das
enden foul von raphael 1511 wir sind im
sechzehnten jahrhundert aber die selbst
schwer unterschied augenfällig oder wenn
man dieses bild hier sich anschauen das
verwundert an als es kommt immer
schlimmer und das ist eines der
eindrücklichsten die schlange wird immer
mehr zu einer frau da hat die frau sogar
brüste also die schlange hat sogar
brüste und einen frauenkopf und
praktisch die gleiche frisur wie die eva
die gleichen haare rote haare gelten
auch als sündhaft also das ist
verführerisch und sie berühren sie fast
als sie die frau und das böse sind
identisch das sagt dieser aussage und da
so wird es in den drei vierhundert
jahren immer schlimmer als es gibt ganz
ganz üble bilde ich habe noch in dem
buch noch viel mehr was passiert in
dieser zeit die man diese bilder
erzählen ja sozusagen aus der zeit
heraus dass man eben früher das neu
aussieht so ist die bibel sieht die
vertreibung aus dem garten eden bis hin
zu heben
das böse wird der frau in die schuhe
geschoben was passiert da im hintergrund
in dieser zeit es ist es ist eine sehr
schlimme zeit alle die ganzen
jahrhunderte die zwei jahrhunderte vor
der reformation die waren eine
katastrophe für die frauen und für die
theologie
das hängt zusammen also die frauen
wurden immer stärker abgewertet es kam
die inquisition auf es kam die
hexenverfolgung aus in dieser zeit wird
auch das übelste machwerk aus dem
spätmittelalter der hexenhammer der
sogenannte hexenhammer geschrieben von
zwei dominikanern dieses buch hat 30
auflagen gehabt und hat 40 400 jahre
dazu gedient die hexen also die
hexenprozesse zu leiten also das waren
anleitungen für die auf lateinisch
natürlich ein anerkennen
da stehen grauenhafte sachen drin also
auch die idee die die zitate aus der
bibel sind grauenhaft ja also so werden
ein paar frauenfeindliche stellen
rausgezogen aus den sprüchen zum
beispiel und und dann zitiert und die
frau ist schlimmer als ein tier sie ist
auch nicht gar kein mensch eigentlich
ist die frau kein mensch und es gab ja
noch bis ins 20 jahrhundert man glaubt
es nicht
bücher die behaupteten frauen wären
keine wirklichen menschen sondern nur
der mann ist ein wirklicher mensch wie
sie es zeigen entbehrt jeglicher
grundlage in der bibel wie kommt denn zu
dieser verteufelung dass hier der
zusammenhang dass dieses
christliche und sexualität so schwierig
zusammen geht und bis zur verteufelung
der sexualität führt ja es geht es geht
ja auch darum dass die frauen ja immer
mit der sexualität verbunden waren also
die männer haben ja sowas nicht sondern
frauen sind fleischlich sie sind sexuell
die aktiven also dass das kommt schon in
der in der vorchristlichen zeit auf bei
so asketischen weise asketischen r
gruppen und das geht nach weiteren der
frühen kirche mit den asketen die leben
ja ohne frauen und wenn was man nicht
haben darf das wird auch verteufelt
sexualität und frauen werden verteufelt
weil die ja angeblich schon am anfang da
kommt es dann am anfang den mann
verführt haben
und man hat dann auch häufig diese
verführung der des adam durch die eva
als eine sexuelle verführung gesehen
das soll ich dir ergibt sie in den
apokryphen ganz scheußlich stellen
also das heißt aber da wo die religion
asketisch wird wo sie sagt ist braucht
diesen weg der reinigung um es wieder
beim gottesbild gott erlangen
da wird sie auch sexuell feindlich ja
eben sie weil weil die die frau also in
dieser in diesen philosophischen
zuschreibungen wo man ja immer die guten
eigenschaften männern das ist eine lange
reihe also gut und böse also mann/frau
himmel erde fleisch geist immer ist die
bessere seite ist ist die männliche
seite die die schwächere ist die frau
stark schwach und so weiter da gibt es
eine ganze latte das geht durch die
ganze abendländische philosophie auch
schon bei den griechen und da ist immer
die frau mit dem fleischlichen also mit
es mit dem sexuellen verbunden
aber ich könnte doch einfach sagen dass
es ausdruck der jeweiligen zeit deshalb
alle eine seele
aber das ist eben die patriarchale
gesellschaft die brauchte einen
sündenbock und das war die frau
und dieses dass das fängt also mit
augustinus an mit dem begriff sündenfall
den hat er geprägt den gibt es vorher
nicht es gibt und augustinus war ja auch
so ein also wirklich kein frauenfreund
das kann man so sagen
aber ich höre aus früher war es besser
wenn ich ins neue testament haben wir
dann briefe des apostels paulus dafür
bietet den frauen zu reden in der
gemeinde und was man sich ja gar nicht
paulus der paulus hat jede menge
kollegin gehabt dieser satz die frau
schweigen der kirche später zugefügt das
ist heute ganz klar bewiesen als es im
zweiten korintherbrief das ist ein satz
der da eingefügt ist er unterbricht
total in zusammenhang
die frauen haben geredet sie haben
gemeinden geleitet hauskirchen ganz
viele frauen also die priska die die die
lüdia die die vögel als unzählige frauen
hatte also die korinther briefe die
werden sie dann diese stellen als
spätere einschübe über dieser eine satz
die frau hat ihn ecclesia zu schweigen
und wenn sie die frauen was wohl
umfragen dann sollen sie zu hause ihre
männer fragen
das ist ganz klar aus der l aus dem ende
des ersten jahrhunderts ist auch nicht
der stil des paulus er schreibt ja im
korintherbrief wenn die frauen
öffentlich reden müssen sie ihren kopf
bedecken will also dabei offensichtlich
in korinth die offenen haare
das hat immer gegolten als irgendwie
etwas für die dieren dass das da die
einen eben gab es war eine hafenstadt
und die frauen die in der gemeinde
redeten und zwar im gottesdienst die
sollten ihren kopf bedecken sie sind
katholische theologin sie an ihre kirche
die stange gehalten ich spring jetzt in
die jetztzeit sie haben den aufbruch mit
dem zweiten vatikanischen konzil in den
60er jahren ganz nah erlebt jetzt hat
mir vor kurzem eine bischofssynode zu
familienthemen da ist diplomatisch
gesagt nicht viel dabei heraus gekommen
enttäuscht sie dass das auch so eine
lange wegstrecke das dann doch nicht
wirklich früchte trägt
also was die frauen jetzt betrieb ist
ich hatte das nicht viel anders erwartet
weil das eben ein sehr sehr langer
prozess ist denn es geht nicht um
kleinigkeiten
also es geht nicht um da eine kleine
änderung deine kleinen es geht wirklich
um einen ganz neuen ansatz und es für
mich ist das selbstverständlich dass
frauen und männer genau die gleichen
möglichkeiten und genau die gleichen
beruflichen chancen und alles genau
gleich gleichberechtigt sein soll in
allen und das wird noch lange dauern
das kann man nicht von einem tag auf den
anderen ändern wie sie ja schon auf dem
weg schon lange all diese bemühungen sie
hatten ja dann einen lehrstuhl in kassel
zum beispiel nach langem ringen
viele fahren die mit ihnen für diese
anliegen gekämpft haben
der ertrag ist also ich denke wir haben
inzwischen ich habe gerade gestern
wieder einen artikel gelesen von einer
kollegin wir haben inzwischen eine große
zahl von frauen auf theologischen
lehrstühlen er in münster in tübingen in
münchen in bern auch das sind das sind
leute die die auch priester ausbilden
und das wird die wirkung mit die wirkung
mit der zeit verstärken also dass die
auch männer sich mit diesen termin ist
themen auseinandersetzen müssen
das haben sie lange nicht getan die
haben das einfach ignoriert inzwischen
gibt es doch sehr viele theologen die
finden das müssen wir jetzt endlich so
kenntnis nehmen da müssen wir uns mit
befassen
und ich denke das braucht einfach noch
länger sie haben ja auch eine petition
eine anregung gemacht dass kardinäle in
der katholischen kirche doch auch frauen
seien könnten dann 1000 für
100 gleichgesinnte mit ihnen
unterschrieben ist da etwas draus
geworden
ich weiß es nicht ich weiß es nicht ob
der papst das bekommen hat und ich muss
irgendwann mal nachfragen muss man zwei
jahre her sie haben gar keine antwort
bekommen ein ich habe keine antwort
bekommen
das ist natürlich frustrierend aber ja
ich meine bei seiner gewichtigen
petition und warum eigentlich kardinäle
ich meinen viele fordern ja
priesterinnen ich finde wir sollten
nicht immer unten anfangen mit dem
diakonat sondern man sollte auch oben
anfangen die berater des popstars sie
berater des papstes es gibt genug eine
ganz ganz prägnante frauen die dafür
toll geeignet wären
für so ein amt und es hat bis bis nach
dem konzil keine weihe gebrauch für die
kardinäle deswegen habe ich das genommen
allerdings haben sie dann nach dem
konzil ich grad 68 haben sie das ins
kirchenrecht gebracht auch die kardinäle
brauchen eine priesterweihe und vorher
war das nicht es gab noch 1 2 war der
weg zurück gar nicht ein so weiter weg
das maya es gab also noch im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert auch leute aus der
wirtschaft und aus der politik die
konnte der papst zu kardinälen machen
dass es ihm freigestellt und er konnte
die als seine berater haben also die
blieben aber geblieben aber laien und
das haben hat irgend jemand gemerkt aber
erst nach dem konzil und setzt dann so
im paragraf noch rein aber das ist
kirchenrecht das wäre wieder bar
also ich bin gespannt hatten sie uns auf
dem laufenden wenn sie eine antwort
bekommen
zum schluss wenn sie an junge menschen
an junge frauen denken was würden sie
ihnen mitgeben
also das kommt darauf an was für junge
frauen wenn sie wenn sie in der kirche
sind würde ich ihnen würde ich ihnen
raten bleibt drin denn nur ihnen kann
man etwas verändern wenn man draußen ist
dann kann man zwar meckern und alles
mögliche kritisieren aber man ist nicht
mehr gehört nicht mehr dazu
also für mich ist die kirche ja nicht
der papst und auch nicht für mich ist
das was anderes das ist meine heimat und
ich würde
den frauen die also gläubig sind sagen
sie sollen so weiter machen einfach
weiter kämpfen und nicht aufgeben die
keinen zugang zur bibel haben ja das was
soll ich ihnen sagen also sie sollen in
ihren eigenen weg gehen also frauen
machen das ja jetzt heute sowieso da
braucht man nicht mehr so da braucht man
keine großen aufforderung mehr und
menschen die engagiert sind in der
kirche können sie deren resignation
frustration auferstehen
ich kann etwas sagen was auch die
herlinde bessere kugel ist schon gesagt
hat meine eine österreichische erste
theologieprofessor in österreich die hat
gesagt ich verstehe jede frau die aus
der kirche austritt
aber ich selber bleibe drin so haben sie
sich auch hier habe ich das auch
entschieden und für mich ist das also
nicht das wesentliche der papst oder rom
ich meine dass es ist nicht das
wesentliche an meinen glauben
ganz herzlichen dank allen schwimmern in
den letzten monaten war ich mehrmals im
vatikan
dort habe ich einen kardinal einen
botschafter und einen schweizer
gardisten begleitet die reportage sehen
sie übermorgen sonntag in der
sternstunde religion
hier geht es jetzt gleich weiter mit dem
neujahrskonzert aus wien
hi